David last time we saw that jesus' early
activities and early teaching put him in
opposition with Jewish leaders along the
way and I wonder if you can tell us how
does that story go in the next section
so as we move our way into chapter 3 and
chapter 4 what continues there well
they're two places work where conflict
immediately shows itself one is more of
these opponents who were already said
were kind of straw people but it's an
interesting combination of the themes we
saw in the first three chapters where
jesus heals somebody who has demon
possession now he's accused of being
demon-possessed and one other thing that
strikes me in reading first century
stuff both Christian and Jewish is that
what nobody denies is that Jesus
performed miracles that may be a problem
for the 21st century in the first
century everybody gave him that the
question was by whose authority did he
do it the rumor against him from the
first century through the first three
and four centuries was he was
essentially a black magician that he was
on Satan side and of course he did
amazing things because he was working
for Satan and what Jesus needs to defend
in in defending his own authority is the
claim that he does wield spiritual power
but the spirit by whose power he acts is
the holy spirit not the demonic spirit
not the satanic spirit and then he gives
us this little speech which Abraham
Lincoln incorporated into American
history that a house divided against
itself cannot stand meaning since I'm
casting out Satan's minions how can that
be Satan doing it I've got to be on the
other side the other side is God's side
and and that just further raises the
opposition but the stakes are raised
this is now not just a bad guy not just
a blasphemer the opposition is now
saying okay and the great battle of good
and evil Jesus is on the evil side and
Jesus says no on the contrary that marks
us on the contrary I'm the
representative the holy spirit of God's
good then the next thing that happens
has always I must say I've found kind of
touching because I think it reflects not
just Jesus life but what it must have
been the life of marks community because
the next people to come in and try to
drag him home or his family and they
think not so much that he's demon
he's just nuts there's a Greek word
which I can't quite remember but the
quick translation is he's nuts let's get
him home and I suspect that reflects
something very real in Jesus own
ministry and life but I suspect it
reflects something very real in the life
of first century Christians that that at
least in my life we were all Christians
by assumption you know grandparents you
betcha
parents absolutely us yep our kids we
hope so but for the first century to do
that Christian thing was a risky thing
to do and I suspect there were plenty of
parents and spouses and cousins saying
oh come home you're just nuts to follow
that man and so we see in the opposition
of Jesus something that was very relayed
his own life but also very real in the
life of the church and we just were just
gonna watch now from from chapter 3
through chapter 15 how he marches ahead
but they're out to get him and that they
grows abundantly it's not now just the
opponents it's now the family and then
we'll see other people who seem to jump
ship or desert or betray he ends up very
lonely and the loneliness begins when he
defines his family and says that it's
those who do the will of his father
you're saying it would resonate with I
think with with with you and me who have
just had to say to our parents I know
you want to stick with the synagogue but
we want to follow this new way and so
you and I now become brothers to
substitute for the biological brothers
that we left not only behind but deeply
annoyed at us yeah yeah so if we're
talking about the the family the the new
family constituted by those who do the
will of God by those who follow Jesus
we've been talking about opponents how
does he how does Jesus walk these people
along the people who are following him
or at least interested yeah and not
opposition yeah my former teacher now
the last deceased and good friend Paul
Minear wanted to argue that when you
look at the character characters are in
Mark's Gospel and we're trying to decide
what characters we are that on the whole
the disciples represent the the circle
that's closest and the crowds represent
the slide
larger circle is interested yeah they're
the ones trying to make up their mind so
in this business of whose family are you
in they're trying to figure out which
family there in the disciples who will
get more and more complicated as we go
along nonetheless have made that basic
decision to be part of Jesus family
they've left Zebedee behind they've left
family behind there
they're now along with him so in chapter
4 we have this interesting moment where
Jesus starts speaking to the crowds then
speaks to the disciples for a while and
in each case he's trying I think to to
help the new family understand what this
new family hood looks like what what
kind of community we are and what kind
of people were going to be and what it's
going to mean to be faithful to this new
Authority and so we get parables so we
got about the Kings understood so the
first real time that Jesus sets up shop
and starts teaching to people everything
else stopped till now has been pretty
interactive and chapter four he turns to
speak parables why two things one thing
having nothing to do with your question
but just an answer I'm prepared to give
anyone there are only two big speeches
in Mark's Gospel unlike Matthew which
has five big speeches mark has just two
big speeches ones this one ones in 13
which will come to a little bit later
and I think they're both speeches about
the kingdom of God
I think I think in Mark's Gospel as
Jesus explicitly says he's there to say
the kingdoms at hand and he's trying to
explain what kingdom looks like and in
chapter 4 he's going to say what does
kingdom look like now and in chapter 13
he's going to say what will Kingdom look
like at the end of time but in both
cases I think mark wants to interrupt
the action long enough for Jesus to make
a fairly complicated full-blown speech
about what is this kingdom that he
preaches and what's it going to mean to
us and so he starts with the crowds and
talked about this parable of the sower
that explains it to his to his more
immediate circle of disciples and then
other parables and I think the point of
all a parable is to say what does
kingdom look like kingdom much dispute
as you know about how best to translate
that phrase kingdom of God because it's
not so much a place like the United
Kingdom which is
England Ireland Wales and Scotland but
the place where the world in which God
was God's sovereignty the sovereignty of
God the reign of God the power of God
what does that look like and I think the
parables are trying to tell us what does
that look like now and then in chapter
13 what will that look like when history
reaches its consummation and so how do
you see the parable the sower which is
our focus this time around
how do you see that doing this picturing
of the kingdom or of the reign of God
yeah the parable of stories is
fascinating to me and here I'm gonna
sound a little pedantic and I quasi
apologize because if you just read the
parable without the explanation the
parable of so our soul goes out to sow
some falls on this ground something
balls on this ground something balls on
this ground some falls on good ground
and grows up huge and terrible everybody
go home I think if you just had that
parable you'd think all right this is
what appeases parables about how little
beginnings end up with great endings
that he is like a soror who goes out to
sow his word and do his miracles and
give you speeches and that some of it
works and some of it doesn't work but
you just keep watching at the end of
time this is going to be an abundant
harvest and the whole world will be
amazed and we'd also great I love this
very much but then in in Mark's Gospel
Jesus brings the disciples inside and
says okay dear friends this is much more
complicated than you think I'm not going
to explain to you that all the different
kinds of soil are different kinds of
reception of the word and if if as we
said we're supposed to see who we are
and Mark's story how much more are we
supposed to ask who are we in this
parable are we the rocky ground are we
the good soil are we the shallow soil
about Marianne Tauber who teaches at
Pacific School of religion wrote a
really good book where she thinks that
that explanation of the parable of the
sower is the best clue to the characters
in Mark's Gospel as we go through asking
who is there
everybody is some kind of character and
the easiest example and he'll come back
a lot is the Blessed st. Peter whose
name you know
Petrus means a rock and we always
thought solid rock on the I'll build my
church that st. Matthew
talking right mark just says rocky and
when when Jesus starts talking about
rocky soil in mark 4 this is not
necessarily good news
that's the soil where you start out
enthusiastically and then the first time
trouble comes you run for the hills well
we're gonna watch rocky and see what
happens when trouble comes and and
Marianne says if you take those
different kinds of soil you can see that
all the way through the different
characters on the gospel represent
shallow hearing or deep hearing easy out
or stay deeply in and and that we're
invited besought to become like the good
soil that receives the word in which it
flourishes and that's that's the insider
information outside you have something
different inside that's a way over one
and another way that that seems to work
for me is by the end of chapter three we
hear these stories of all kinds of
people coming from everywhere and there
are geographic offenses that take you
all up and down the coast and and inland
and all these people are cut rock star
Jesus's rock star
it may be a good question going into for
how many people in this group are gonna
stick it out absolutely and and so as
Mary Ann Tolbert has said and as the
action turns toward the parable it could
be a sorting principle yeah it could be
a sort of principle and and the good
question is is there any good soil by
the end of the by the end of the book
right well that's a huge question and
the other the other place where this
gets puzzling to me is if if you were to
ask me just why do you think Jesus tells
parables I would say Jesus tells
parables to help people understand to
make the kingdom accessible and I'm a
preacher you're a preacher what we tell
stories the purpose of our they may
confuse people but that's not why we
tell them that's just an unfortunate
side a side effect of that telling it
very well when it works this will say ah
now I understand so I've always thought
okay Jesus sells parables and everybody
says ah now I understand now
phooey he tells a parable and he says
okay disciples come here here's why I'm
telling these parables I'm telling these
parables to confuse people
I'm telling these parables to sort out
my real family from the fake family
you guys are gonna get it they're not
going to get it and this is gonna be a
mystery that's only for you and only for
insiders and now we're not just thinking
okay everybody come in we're thinking
who's an insider who's an outsider how
do we decide who's inside and outside
how can I be inside how can I stay
inside and what do I risk and all this
and it's it just it switches the whole
thing my own suspicion and I know this
is this is a 21st century suspicion my
own suspicion is that Jesus told
parables the way we preach sermons to
help people understand that it's mark
who's worried about this inside-outside
thing and that's a device that he uses
to tell his story not a device Jesus
would have used to tell his own gospel
so Jesus used them to elucidate mark use
them to separate oh yeah and and the the
interesting next step in mark will be
the just as you're starting to think
that the disciples are in fact exactly
they're not going to exactly and and so
it back to the question of whether we
end up with any good soil at the end of
the we'll just have to track that right
yeah as a person living trying to live
out faith in the 21st century
I wonder am i rocky soil am i good soil
am i what what kind of my is that a good
question for me to ask that's a huge I
think it's a hugely good question for
you to ask there's enough of a I am
enough of a lover of the Blessed st.
Paul to think that if you ask it too
much you're gonna spend all your time
introspecting ly worrying about Alan Sol
and not X respectively thinking about
how do I serve the world with gladness
but nonetheless I think yes of course we
eat why to examine ourselves and see
where we are so we could I mean you're
you're nice caution from st. Paul we
could turn ourselves around and say
let's stop looking at the soil and start
looking at the sower right yeah we can
let you see this sort of throws and how
hard this sower is trying to get
something to grow and and in the way
Jesus Jesus and Mark help us do that
because the next parables have to do
with this mustard seed that turned into
a huge plant right Oh in in the first
parish which I served what about
favorite parishioners was a plant
pathologist and plant pathologists are
ones who know a great deal about
Agriculture and I could not preach on
the agricultural parables
without him correcting me the Buster's
he's not that little on the mustard
bushes not that big and Jesus mark and I
had all got it wrong and he had wonder
who explained that to me
but Jesus point whether agriculturally
right or not was theologically seems to
me deep and powerful which is that this
whole Christian thing is about stuff
that seems small but has enormous
implications and that's all good news
yeah and add the story about the seed
that's going down there and finally pops
up that's good news too and in a way it
gets us away from our anxiety the words
working away and we have to watch for it
it's not so much what kind of soil I am
its keep your eyes open so that when God
does a great thing we can say hooray and
be part of that yeah and you know
there's the parable of the wheat and
tares that comes later in the chapter
also it takes the pressure off us to
decide who's in and who's out and that's
that's another danger of the parables of
the sower that we can end up looking
around trying to define who's who and
later in the chapter Jesus is going to
say you know what let us take care of
that yeah yeah right we don't have you
don't have to define that there will be
some wheat and some tears we'll sort it
out at the end yeah so so what I'm
hearing then is that the parables of
chapter 4 bring the first three chapters
to a teaching moment and the kingdom of
God becomes central to what Jesus wants
to lay out for people in words exactly
and so so we move now next to actions of
Jesus and we'll catch those next time
absolutely thank you thank you